[Music]
so you think tinder is a recent
phenomenon what if i told you tinder on
paper existed back in the victorian days
here's what happened
[Music]
way before hallmark people used personal
calling cards to connect with each other
picture this
it was the late 1800s a man and a woman
crossed paths they exchanged a look in
return the man passed his card
see society at that time was very formal
and not satisfied with the stiff social
conventions youngsters got creative
enter escort cards the calling card with
a twist think of the most ridiculous and
cheesy pickup line you've ever heard
written on a card come and see our new
lamp you can turn it down so low there's
scarcely any light at all ps our sofa
just holds two i'm just your size and
complexion i'm going in your direction
so if you have no objection i'd like to
be your protection
i am cy young who the devil are you
now picture that card slipped to you it
was a way to flirt in public without
anyone ever knowing may i have the
pleasure of seeing you home this evening
and in this case oh she swiped left
sorry
[Music]